you are enjoying your family
on a weekend on a saturday morning and
you receive an email and even
although you know that it's your private
time
that it's your family time that it's
your rest time you still feel that you
are
obliged to reply parliament wants
workers free time to be protected from
work related calls messages or emails
meps are calling on the commission to
draw up rules regulating digital work
tools
and allowing employees to switch off
when they're not on the clock
if the need for a right to disconnect
without facing repercussions was already
present
it's been underscored by the kovit 19
pandemic
the timing is more right today because
the
prevalence of teleworking the prevalence
of
smart working flexor working is being
felt
more right now in 2020 more than one in
three europeans began working from home
that means the boundaries between
professional and private life get blurry
people working from home often work
longer and more irregular hours
always being reachable can affect
work-life balance and physical and
mental health
[Music]
currently no eu legislation explicitly
states that europeans have the right to
disconnect without repercussion
meps want to put an end to the always on
culture
and have switching off recognized as a
fundamental right
you